Шуби, хутряні шапки і комірці,
а разом із ними і хутрові ферми -
усе це у Європі поволі відходить у минуле.
Тим часом в Україні ця галузь процвітає.
Понад 600 тисяч - саме стільки тварин
щороку вбивають на українських хутрових фермах.
І ця цифра може збільшитися, якщо через суворі заборони
європейські хутровики перенесуть свій бізнес до України.
Виробництво хутра має давні традиції у країнах Європи.
Загалом на континенті - п’ять тисяч хутрових ферм -
саме з цього регіону походить половина світового хутра.
Попри це дедалі більше країн Євросоюзу
відмовляються від такого бізнесу.
Хутрові ферми, приміром, вже повністю заборонені
в Австріїта Великобританії.
Данія, Бельгія та Естонія - на перехідному етапі
до повної відмови від хутрових ферм.
Тоді як у Німеччині, Швеції та Іспанії
діють настільки суворі приписи у цій галузі,
що переважна більшість таких підприємств вже закрилися.
У ФРН, приміром, десять років тому було
30 хутрових ферм, нині залишилися лише одиниці.
Втім, у цього, здавалось би, позитивного процесу є і зворотній бік.
Адже на тлі закриття хутрових ферм у країнах ЄС
іноземні виробники почали переміщати свій бізнес в Україну.
Тут порівняно лояльне законодавство і дешева робоча сила.
Приміром, у селищі Сінгури, на Житомирщині,
працює хутрова ферма з Нідерландів.
Заявки на будівництво таких підприємств останнім часом
подали ще кілька іноземних інвесторів.
Серед них, зокрема, данські хутровики, які мають намір
побудувати ферму так само на Житомирщині, у селі Квітневе.
Якщо ці заявки схвалять, попереджають захисники тварин,
обсяги діяльності хутрових ферм в Україні
збільшаться одразу вдвічі - з понад 600 тисяч
до понад 1 мільйона 300 тисяч вбитих тварин на рік.
Доля данського поректу вирішуватиметься на громадських слуханнях.
Через безробіття селяни часто погоджуються на будівництво,
сподіваючись на нові робочі місця, і не замислюються
про шкоду хутрового виробництва.
Офіційно в Україні, за даними активістів, працюють 37 хутрових ферм.
Понад 95% тварин, яких вирощують заради хУтра - норки.
Зоозахисники нарікають на умови, в яких утримують тварин -
зокрема, тісні брудні клітки,  які обмежують їхнє пересування,
примусове харчування модифікованими продуктами,
а також жорстокі методи вбивства заради красивого хутра.
Таке виробництво не лише жорстоке щодо тварин,
але й завдає шкоди довкіллю та здоров’ю людей,
попереджають у Міністерстві охорони здоров’я Україні.
За рівнем забруднення довкілля токсичними речовинами
Світовий банк відносить хутрові ферми
до п'ятірки найбільш шкідливих виробництв.
Вони забруднюють ґрунт, водойми та повітря
вірусами, бактеріями й токсичними речовинами.
Альтернативою натуральному хутру могли б стати новітні розробки.
Світові бренди одягу масово відмовляються від натурального хутра
на користь штучного, яке завдяки сучасним технологіям
на вигляд і дотик нічим не відрізняється від справжнього.